kind of like a skater has a skateboarder
BMX air has a bike I just saw the
wheelchair something fun so why not take
it into the park I'm Erin wheels
bothering him and I ride w c MX w cm X
stands for wheelchair motocross it's you
know taking your chair into the skate
park and hitting ramps kind of the same
thing as BMX but with a wheelchair I
first started going to the skate parks
when I was eight years old and I've been
doing it for 16 years now the wheelchair
is definitely just an extension of my
body because skaters aren't always on
their skateboard and bikers aren't
always on their bike but I'm always on
my chair so that gives me like an unfair
advantage to just practice everywhere I
go I feel like I'm lucky that I always
have my wheelchair with me because I can
just jump whenever I want I was born
with spina bifida I've had 21 surgeries
throughout my life and I spent a lot of
time in the hospitals and yeah it would
be easy to just be bummed out on that
but I was for me I just found the
positive the wheelchairs just always
been fun and it's wheels stuck to your
butt how's that not a great time in 2008
I got the Guinness world record for the
first backflip on a wheelchair now is
that a local competition here in Vegas
called am Jim
that was a pretty cool day one of my
favorite tricks is just simple handplant
because I always loved watching skaters
do it when I was growing up and you know
watching the pros do it it just was
something I wanted to learn
I'm very blessed to be able to do what I
love and what I'm passionate about for a
living a lot of the time the wheelchair
comes with the stereotype of you can't
do this or whatever because it's a
medical device
I just always seen the wheelchair is a
great opportunity